[Music]
this is the true meaning of christmas
right here
give me hey guys
it's me jasmine i'm feeling super
festive today
because we're gonna be making cocoa buns
you've probably seen them all over your
tik tok
but if you haven't they are these molded
chocolate balls
filled with hot cocoa toppings and we're
going to be making a few variations of
those today
including one for cider lovers can't
forget you cider lovers
let's begin i'm so excited
so the first cocoa bomb we're gonna do
is a white chocolate peppermint one
i have my white chocolate morsels and
we're gonna melt this down
[Music]
one minute once that melts down we will
brush it into our silicone molds
you guys learned juggling in middle
school i remember that oh i didn't keep
a lookout for the time
oh what's wrong with me all right let's
give this a little mix
kind of smells like cheese this is the
first year i've purchased
holiday pajamas i feel like i've been
missing out my whole life now
like i put these on and i'm instantly so
happy this looks pretty good
so we can begin to brush these into the
molds
and then it'll give it time to harden i
might need a pastry brush for this
do you think chocolatiers as kids they
were like
i want to be a chocolatier when i grow
up why didn't we dream of that
let me switch to my pastry brush this is
so much better
i pour too much chocolate it's not
dispersing evenly
because we need to melt down the edges
in a bit let's just get rid of this
excess chocolate you need to clean it
when the chocolate's
hot otherwise it will crack oh no
they cracked i should have done it oh
this is where i'm messing up
okay my confidence has definitely just
continued to
decrease but i'm optimistic because i've
got the
holiday spirit i'm gonna pop this in the
fridge
oh no there's no space this is why you
don't
go to the grocery store hungry there's
no space in your fridge after that
and now we're gonna take them out of the
molds i see people using gloves
to avoid fingerprints so that's what i'm
gonna do too
we got our first one pretty smooth
it cracked oh my god
i'm gonna start it off with some hot
cocoa powder
little truffle inception or marshmallows
and of course you can't forget your
pretty sprinkles
oh my god so cute so now we're going to
decorate the tops
i have my red candy melt no
now i'm going to do with the chocolate
which seems to have melted
no it's not working it's definitely
not as cute as i want it to be but
because it's still wet i'm going to
sprinkle some
crushed peppermint cute both the bottom
and the tops of the cocoa bomb are done
so i've heated up a pan over here
so we're gonna melt down those bottoms
not too long not too long
put it on top of here gotta work quickly
oh
look at that oh my god forgot to wear
gloves
there's fingerprints on this look how
cute it is
oh my goodness now that all our cocoa
bombs are complete we can go ahead
and drink them so we're gonna grab our
mug put a cocoa bomb inside
and slowly pour over hot milk
come here oh my
god oh that's crazy
oh my god beautiful
that looks so good stir it with my candy
cane
oh my god i want to try it that looks so
good oh my god this is so cool
the last step whipped cream
and let's not be afraid for some extra
sprinkles
oh that's so cool
oh my so god
oh i want more it's so chocolaty
slightly peppermint
that is really good that's a bang okay
let's move on to the next one
this one is the butterscotch cocoa bomb
for our cider
i know some people don't love hot
chocolate
uh but to each their own and some people
prefer cider
so i have some melted butterscotch right
here
make the outsides again my butterscotch
is grainy which i think means i burnt it
that just continues my streak of
messing up melting chocolate so i'm
gonna try letting it set by layers so
i'll do this first one
and then pop it in the fridge and let
this set and do
one more layer so i did the second layer
and let it set again
seems pretty good and a lot faster than
just pouring it
and kind of pushing it up along the
sides in one take so i recommend doing
it in layers
let's hope none of these are i also
already cleaned out
the sides
[Music]
[Music]
okay i'll fix that we have the three
bottoms let's add our toppings
for this one i'm going a little fruitier
i feel like it goes with the vibe more
these are some dried pomegranates
after the pomegranate gotta add some dry
apples
and finally just gonna add some white
chocolate chips
i was gonna add the glitter in there
again but because it sunk in the last
one
learning from our mistakes and we're not
gonna add them in this time we'll just
put it on top of the whipped cream let's
go add the tops
i am going to do a white chocolate
drizzle and top
it with those pretty fall sprinkles
yay look how festive this is i'm
obsessed with this
i'm not gonna lie when i first saw a
cocoa bomb tick tock i was like
that's right that's cool look at me now
this is like
so fun as a craft activity and then you
get to drink it and eat it afterwards
and it's sugar and it makes you happy
i'll take any happiness i can get this
here now we just got to put the tops on
the cocoa bombs oh my god this one's way
meltier
i need my gloves this one feels so
fragile
it's sticking
[Music]
apply pressure apply pressure okay i was
scared for a second it was melting at
like
super speed okay oh
oh my god look how pretty they are
my cocoa bomb babies i love them welcome
to the family my friends
now that the cocoa bombs are put
together it's time to make these guys
explode
i brought my boyfriend back for another
coco bomb experience he seemed to really
enjoy the first one
so this one is the butterscotch
cocoa bomb for cider oh that sounds
really good
all right baby you ready for this cider
bomb heck yeah
we're gonna put the butterscotch bomb
over there into the mug
oh it's so pretty i don't even want to
ruin it
the magic begins oh wow that looks so
festive this is the true meaning of
christmas right here
beautiful what is it dried apples dried
pomegranate and then there's
a few uh white chocolate morsels in
there and then i have a cinnamon stick
we're gonna stir it of course whipped
cream
and the fall glitter oh wow
thanks okay i'm gonna sip it from the
table first
that's oh
man that's like an apple pie but in
liquid form oh
yeah yeah yeah isn't this so good
i didn't believe in the dried apples but
that's so good gimme
this bomb huh that's good no pun
intended i feel like this should be on
our holiday menu
who isn't this going to impress on to
the next one last but
certainly not least if not probably
the most we have the new year's themed
cocoa bomb
what am i doing with my hands i don't
know i have super
dark chocolate here i've already melted
it brush it up along the sides
for the next three i'm going to start
sprinkling in
my edible gold stars in and it'll have
it as
the top this one needs to be very
sparkly because when i think of new
years
i think of going all out all right now
i'm gonna drizzle this chocolate over
the stars so now that i have some
chocolate in there i'm gonna slowly
brush it up
careful to not pick up any of the stars
but more like just brush the chocolate
over them
hopefully we still see some stars after
it sets
also force comes to worst we could just
redecorate it no problemo
i took out all the chocolates from the
mold the tops came out beautifully i'm
very pleased with them
now we're just gonna go ahead and build
these cocoa bombs
i have dark chocolate hot cocoa powder
here and i was gonna have
different sprinkles for the inside but
someone stole them off my front
porch if you stole my sprinkles off my
front porch
you're on the naughty list i'm gonna add
these gold
star sprinkles from earlier gonna add
some marshmallows
now we're going hard here chocolate
liqueurs
for one of them i will do a fancy
macaron
cute wow this is so fancy
we lost one it melted while i was
setting up the camera
and now we'll never know its true
potential
oh god it's cracking ah
we did it we got it it is on two lovely
cocoa bombs are completed
ripped to our friend that didn't make it
babe one more cocoa bomb he ran down
very quickly he's very excited for this
last super excited
okay ready you don't even know what's in
here yet oh
oh my god oh no you can't see
ah oh my i thought it was a huge
marshmallow is that a macaron it's a
macaron
i'm gonna mix it up real quick oh i'm
seeing a lot of chocolate in there
you know what this is probably gonna
melt
is it hot it's good yeah that's so good
of course whipped cream
let's add a few more glittery stars
and of course we need oh
wow that is gorgeous
shall we try yes
mmm yellow sun
you wanna try oh that's so good i really
want the soul
okay why don't you just take that over
there you can enjoy that careful okay
it's trippy
all right guys i would call that a
success overall i feel like we made
three
beautiful cocoa bombs i totally see the
hype around cocoa bombs now they're just
so pretty and it's fun to make of the
ones we made today i would say that the
butterscotch cider one was my favorite
it was just super unique just made me
love cider even more
let me know in the comments below what
food i should make next and if you end
up making any cocoa bombs make sure to
tag me on instagram
happy holidays bye oh
[Music]
yes
[Music]
you